biohacker 45 years old uh what's this
guy's name Brian Johnson all right he
spent two million dollars a year trying
to de-age himself he now gets injected
with the blood of his teenage son first
of all look how scary that son of a
looks trying to go pale demon like
dude is that that looks like a robot
obviously the blood isn't helping him
okay so he follows a strict diet and
workout regime and has managed to shave
off some of the years he's accumulated
he's now he's not he's 45 he's finding
out the secret of Youth he's been
injected with his son's blood undergone
blood transfusions with a stranger he
was like you know what my 17 year old
son uh Talmage weird ass name and like
what what the hell is going on he's
getting blood from his kid how dare you
do that to your child to make yourself
better
your child of course wants to please you
I'm sure he wants to make his dad happy
of course wants his dad to live longer
how could you let him do that over and
over again and the the Grandpa's
involved the grandfather uh yeah Richard
seven years old he's giving blood too
what what it makes me sick like like
this is like a new modern day version of
like a vampire Clan it's disgusting bro
he's getting blood from his 17 year old
son and his 70 year old father Richard
let me explain something to you all
right okay
we all have something in common every
one of us tall short black white asian
female listen we all have an expiration
date you're all going to die you're just
delaying the inevitable to like hang on
to that and and dude you know just force
others to suffer because they're trying
to help you like that kid's wasting
hours and and blood
I don't under like because you're a
selfish and you want to keep you
want to look young you're inside you're
gonna listen the clock is still ticking
you're not gonna be here forever bro I
think it's disgusting and then Bo if you
think about he's doing that think about
what other Rich Elite famous people do
that's why now you know when you hear
people like all kids disappear and they
want their blood gross that right there
that right there makes me think that if
he's multi dude if he's spending two
million dollars a year Kelly think how
much money he has imagine the rich rich
rich people that you don't even know who
they are what are they doing to get
those little I want to be young friends
yeah I feel like we're going into sci-fi
oh